[Music]
one day my family was building this
fence around my chicken my chicken coop
because there were problems with
raccoons um and we wanted to make sure
that like the the perimeter of the fence
was like
twice the length of the
of the width and i remember thinking
this is exactly like my algebra class
like i'm actually doing things that are
um
useful and actually like algebra wasn't
just something that you do on paper it's
something that like it was actually like
protecting the lives of my chickens so i
felt like that was a moment for me where
like
math is useful to the world and we're
solving real problems with it and it's
really powerful so i realized that i
first liked algebra and just math in
general my first year in college it was
a little bit of a late bloomer in
realizing the importance of math i was
taking an early statistics course for my
psychology degree
and i really began to understand how the
concepts that i were learning
could help me understand the world
around me better in a more concrete um
fluid and rich way and so being able to
make that connection from these things
that i'm learning in the classroom out
into the real world so i can understand
different phenomenon i can understand um
how various things in our culture work
and progress
really helped me and made me feel like i
had a deeper understanding for the
importance
of math and algebra and from that point
i've really been in love
[Music]
you